roommate meeting roommate meeting don't
go what the hell I've got a hangover I
don't give up about your hangover okay
Brendan I want a roommate meeting and
want it not okay somebody's been taking
out of the frigerator and throwing it on
the ground and it's pissing me off is
this another one of your stupid pranks
jonald no and your pranks are stupid
is it you Monday what I said somebody's
been taking out of the fridge and throw
it on the grind and I want to know who
it is because it's not funny but what I
want to know is who keeps pulling the
sheets off my bed and hanging them from
the ceiling fan at night was that you
Monday what have you been taking
everybody's sheets off them in the night
and hanging them from the ceiling fans
what no well clearly someone's been
doing that whoa who did that yeah who
did that
what's funny you just threw that Bob
what are we even talking about right now
did you throw that bottle jonald no go
go
you I didn't do it whooping you control
that bottle Brendon yeah you would do
that friend II don't know the bottle
well somebody threw that in bottle and
you're the one who drew dicks on
everyone's forehead yeah
you did do that but gets hilarious
though this is just a struck it what
about you Monday did you throw that
bottle what bottle the skin bottle dude
it's
smash against the wall and you even set
some doubt it I didn't throw bottle
obviously it wasn't paying he's got the
best grades in the house
good pointing come on guys let's cool it
with the profanity
you know pings very religious hey man
what's up
she's doing what's with the Robin
Williams routine man what's going on
this is what I do every day
Kris pulling my teeth what what's the
matter the black guys making way too
much noise in your movie theater messed
up are we just stand again is my sight
Oh who's your favorite character
my fellow his might as well tis mine as
well I wish I were high on pop where are
you gonna grab my breath now unreal look
at these clouds that was my joke damn
straight
whoo hey nonny nonny saying hey nonny
nonny